limburgerhof doch wenn du siehst kriegst
du es nie
hallo leute ich jetzt wieder einmal
wanne und in diesem video soll es über
tattoos gehen über meine tattoos wenn
ich ja schon wieder getan ich habe mir
ein neues tattoo stechen lassen doch
bevor ich mein neues tattoo zeige zeige
ich euch mal meine ganzen anderen tattoo
viele von euch wollten unbedingt mal
wissen was die bedeutung dahinter ist
und an welchen körperstellen ich tattoos
habe mein allererstes spiel mit 18
stichen leaf ist das hier ein anker auf
dem rücken ich weiß macht mich stolz auf
dieses tattoo war und meine eltern war
mega schockiert und meinten die ganze
zeit die ahnung dass in einem jahr
wieder bereuen und das ist mittlerweile
schon fünf jahre her und ich habe bisher
zwar nicht bereut ich bin immer noch
super strahlt die bedeutung dahinter ist
ganz einfach der anker steht für hamburg
weil ich die hälfte meines lebens dort
verbracht hat und die kirschblüten
stehen für das alte land in dem ich dann
meine zweite hälfte verbracht habe und
ja das ist so eine verbindung von beiden
ist der klassische statur und ja für
mich liegt eigentlich ganz so klassisch
diktatur ist mein zweites tattoo und
lisa pitt will mit den wasserfarben
drumherum bin habe ich mir vom künstler
voller kontrast stechen lassen und das
andere war von mccormick habe ich
vergessen zu sagen zu ihm bin ich damals
hingegangen und meinte ja ich male gerne
und ich dachte vielleicht zum generell
das irgendwie so ein märz wahrheit und
ich wusste schon dass er immer so
komische also nicht komisch aber er
benutzt hat immer so ganz kollegen
farben und linien und so und das fand
ich immer ganz cool
und ja ich hatte bis vor dem tag an dem
ich da war oder ob es an dem tag an dem
ich da war wusste ich noch nicht wie es
aussehen wird als ich dann im studio
angekommen meinte er zu mir ja ich habe
nichts vorbereitet liegt ich mal hin und
dann fing an mit stiften auch meinem
einzug von ungefähr so vorgestellt und
ich mag damit meinen süßen 19 jahren und
war okay dann mach mal und ich muss
ehrlich sagen dass ich echt nicht bereut
habe einfach die hand alles in seiner
hand zu geben
denn total schön geworden und ich mag es
heute und viele leute sind immer total
verwundert wenn sie das hier sehen
denken möchte einen blauen fleck aber es
ist kein blauer fleck dabei nur ja und
ich mag es richtig gerne etwas sagen
möchte obwohl ich fasse wenn leute
bewusst sagen ich habe vorher
die aquarell cartoons gesehen und ich
dachte ich bin total cool wenn ich ein
aquarell datum habe und danach kommt er
sich getrennt und dann hat ein anderer
aquarell tattoos ist schön also ich hab
mir klingt ein mensch was schön ist dann
wird zum trend aber ich habe es sofort
kohl bei jahr was ich mir noch stechen
liest du four school war diese origami
vogel jetzt hab ich mir recht schnell
nach den verstecken dass man die
bedeutung dahinter ist sehr ausgefuchst
genau ich hab mir zu meinem abitur
sprechen lassen und zwar dachte ich dass
ich als ich in die schule gekommen bin
ein zusammengeknotet blatt papier wurde
und während der ersten phase bis zur
zehnten klasse wurde ich glatt
gestrichen und weil's abitur in der
fachrichtung gestaltung hatte wurde ich
quasi dann auf dem glatten papier zu
einem vogel gefaltet schon in die
richtige richtung und dann in die welt
raus gelassen wenn man verstehen will
damit sagen möchte dazu nummer vier ein
blumenstrauß für diesen boom streit gibt
es tatsächlich auch eine ganz wichtige
geschichte und zwar habe ich damals für
fantastisch ein video über tattoos
machen wollen und da dachte ich mir wär
doch witzig wenn es dann auch eine tour
in diesem video dann bekomme und damit
seine tätowiererin hingegangen und dann
hab ich mir nicht schnell überlegt aber
ich hatte doch schon jetzt einen
expliziten wunsch aber ich habe dann
einfach darüber nachgedacht was ich bin
marc und macke sträuße und hab dann wie
ein blumenstrauß zeichnen lassen den
fand ich ganz schön und dann habe ich in
blumenstrauß bekommen und es gibt sogar
dieses video glaub ich noch ich verlinke
euch das mal irgendwo und schon kann
durch bisher fantastisch geht nicht
weiter mich fragen wir ganz viele leute
waren fantastisch weitergeht das geht
nicht bei crysis wobei leute wenn die
fernseh karriere ist vorbei
habe ich mir in sonnen stechen lassen
und war reich dort für das harry potter
theaterstück und eines abends darf mit
einem burger laden und haben darüber
nachgedacht und tattoos stechen zu
lassen weil man ja in london ist und wo
einer und dafür gegenüberliegenden seite
war dann ein tattoo laden der ganz cool
aus da und dann hab ich mir einen termin
gemacht und tattoos gekommen einmal
diese tasse und natürlich harry potters
habe die bedeutung dahinter ich mag
harry potter und von großbritannien cool
und jetzt kommt das datum was ich mir
vor ein paar tagen habe stechen lassen
die leute ob instagram haben jetzt schon
gesehen ich habe mir schon so lange
pocahontas aus
gewünscht und zwar die aus dem disney
film pocahontas und wann ich mir so sehr
gewünscht habe habe ich zu meinem
tätowierer anvertraut beziehungsweise
hatte immer angst ist nicht so werden
wird wie ich mir vorstelle und dann ist
diese chance doch heute tut dann
vergeben und das ist dann für immer und
ich muss damit leben dass ich keinen
richtigen tätowierer gefunden habe oder
mir nicht genug mühe gemacht hat den
richtigen zu finden aber ich kann euch
sagen ich habe den richtigen gefunden
vor michaela frey und nach südamerika
war wie hier bei mir in berlin und hat
sich von einer tätowiererin einen platz
reservieren lassen
die lehrerin heißt martha und ich fand
ihre arbeiten so wunderschön habe aber
dann bin ich zurück die zeit gefunden
und letztens hat sie dann auf instagram
gepostet dass sie wieder zurück nach
polen zieht und dann habe ich meine
chance genutzt da sich viele von euch
einen tag gewünscht haben habe ich mal
meine kamera mitgenommen um alle
eindrücke einzufangen und werde euch
jetzt mal erzählen wie das denn so bei
einem termin zu termin abläuft und
worauf man achten muss zuerst muss du
dir ein tattoo artist aus den tiefen
fall hatte ich ein glück weil ich habe
ich mir selber sehen konnte wie
ordentlich bearbeitet konnte der sv
wehen und hab dann auf jeden fall
gemerkt dass was ich richtige wenn ihr
also einen künstler gefunden hatte laden
gefällt gibt es zwei sachen wir tun
können erstens kommt mit einer genauen
vorstellung was ihr wollt oder ihr lasst
die entscheidung größtenteils warum
tätowieren und wenn ihr eine genaue
vorstellung von dem tattoo haben sie
haben wollt dann versucht es so gut wie
möglich dem 5 nahe zu bringen weil er
nicht in euren kopf ein schauer so alles
geben zu kitten was auch immer also ich
habe vorher ein abenteuer habe ich eine
skizze gezeichnet und marta hat dann die
spitze genommen
wir haben dann besprochen wie diesen um
ungefähr haben möchte und dann habt ihr
das auf ein anderes blatt papier in
sauber abgezeichnet da so eine finte
dann dran
das konnte wieder einfach auf meine haut
drauf legen abziehen damit sie halt gut
weiß wo sie schwächen muss das dann
einfach wieder eigene farbe die dann
auch beim armen und dann wurde
losgesprochen zuerst die outlines mit
wenigen nadeln oder seine kopfhaut
einfachen das zu den meisten eigentlich
nicht so doll weh nie hat es überhaupt
nicht weh getan es war super entspannt
ich hab kein schmerz gespürt da es auf
jeder anders muss man sagen und man muss
sagen die körperstelle ist halt auch
wichtig bei der oberarm ist sehr
schmerzfrei würdige sagen wobei der
unterarm hat sehr schnell empfindlich
ist am besten
kann man das herausfinden wenn man sich
kneifen man sich hier tut es ganz schön
weh wenn man sich hier um knallt merck
ist einfach kauft was ich ganz übel
findet wenn auf knochen gestochen wird
also wenn sich unter der haut direkt in
knochen befindet dann vibriert der ganze
körper ein bisschen an wie beim fahren
und alles in ordnung ist mein held aus
es gibt aber auch leute die nicht so
schmerzfrei sind also maas hat erzählt
dass manche leute echt barrierefreien
und heulen und eine hat sich sogar mal
ein gepinkelt weil sie auf toilette
schon musste und es plötzlich so weh
getan hat dass sie es nicht mehr halten
konnte von erfahrungen habe ich noch
nicht gemacht bei mir was eigentlich mal
relativ gut ich bin aber auch ein ich
nicht beim augenbrauen zupfen wenn ich
unendlich wenn ich mir mal die beine
gewachst hat es war für mich nie so
schlimm wie manche für manch anderes wir
haben insgesamt ungefähr sieben stunden
an dem tattoo gesetzen und nach den
outlines kam ja die farbe also da wurde
alles ausgefüllt und selbst das hat mir
nicht wehgetan
nur die letzte halbe stunde da war mein
körper schon müde und er einfach fix und
alle nach sieben stunden war er noch
längere weder noch vorher gefeiert haben
aber so nach sieben stunden war dein
körper einfach fertig so und dania hat
wieder halt noch weiter gemacht und wir
mussten uns fertig kriegen weil sie
arbeit weg ist und da keine zeit mehr
gewesen wäre man kann ja auch große
tattoos kann man auch im zweifel zu
machen ein letztes mal stecken und dann
wird weiter gesprochen
wir müssen uns an einem tag machen die
wahrheit besser wie man einen tattoo
nach dem stechen pflegt ist eine
wissenschaft für sich weil jeder
tätowierer eine andere meinung hat der
eine sagt nimm die folie nach drei
stunden ab
also man kriegt nachdem florian eine
folie drauf oder ein pflaster das kannst
du dir einfach draufgehalten
aber wenn du zb diese folie hat dann
sagen nach drei stunden der andere sagt
hier am nächsten morgen wer andere was
am abend dann mit wie man es abwäscht
der eine möchte dass du niemals
küchentuch rüber was der andere sagt mit
wasser überlaufen
also es gibt 100 möglichkeit was wir
aber jeder to be a sagt muss auf jeden
fall braucht ist eine wunderbar sonst
immer die vom bka täglich benutzt die
antiseptische und dann habe ich letztens
von einer freundin eine tattoo pflege
seibel bekommen direkt nach dem stechen
von valea 5% panthenol drin ich glaube
das war heute die entzündungen hemmt ist
auch sehr beruhigend also ich hab mit
der jetzt richtig gute erfahrungen
gemacht also die besten verstreichen
ich bin nicht gesponsert bei gm oder so
würde das empfehlen weil die glaube ich
recht günstig auf ist weil die wand ihn
kostet ja
die sind teuer gibt auch welche von
anderen markus babbel liegt auch ein
vorteil sein aber wie finde ich wirklich
gut die benutze ich wäre gerne wenn ihre
empfindliche haut da könnt ihr diese
creme auch wunderbar nach dem rasieren
benutzen um fertige vorzubeugen wird
wunder nun so als kleiner tipp am rand
und jetzt zeige ich euch endlich mein
neues tattoo weil die bereit
ich liebe du landest 4 und gleicht
gehört dir alles das land würdig frei
und nur noch hohn und jeder steinen baum
und jedes wesen hat sein leben seine
ziele seine stolz für dich für echte
menschen nur die menschen die so denken
und so aussehen wie du doch folgen den
spuren eines brennt dann stehst du und
du lernst noch was dazu ich hoffe
natürlich hat das video gefallen und
wenn ihr wissen wollt was es damit auf
sich hat dann schaut auf jeden fall das
nächste video
bis dahin gibt einen daumen nach oben
abonniert main kanal und freut euch des
lebens genießt den sommer genießt die
liebe genießt geblieben
menschen tiere lachen tanzen welt wo
menschen leben tanzen welt